one of the things that really upset me
for a long time was the fact that I had
great ideas and intentions and I wanted
to manifest them and I thought this is
how it's going to manifest and so I had
all these visions of how things were
going to unfold and then I'd started
processing it wouldn't unfold and then
it would irritate me because like I've
got to make it work I gotta make it work
ultimately I started to recognize when
things didn't work it was possibly
because there were better ways to do it
and I wasn't conscious of it and so what
I started to learn over a period of time
was simply this there's an old saying
there's a means to an end and the idea
well the end is your destination and of
course the means are how you're going to
get to that destination well of course
all of us sit down and say yeah this is
what I want and then we start to figure
out well this is what I'll do to get to
those ends I'll get to this and I'll get
to this to get to the end what I started
to realize at some point was maybe my
awareness of how to get to the end
wasn't exactly accurate and it turns out
many of the times when things didn't
work and I was like so upset it didn't
work but it turned out oh there was a
better way to get there and I didn't
even know it so the universe was really
facilitating me and I wasn't paying
attention I was getting angry at the
universe because like it's not working
in a way I want it to work and then I
started to realize some point was my God
maybe the universe has a better solution
than the one I was even thinking of
myself hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because when I started
my first business I really struggled to
believe myself I was making 300 bucks a
month and quit on my business partner
and the thing that saved me was watching
the stories of successful entrepreneurs
they gave me strategies as well as hope
and belief that just maybe I could do it
myself as well and I hope that this
video here today helps you get a little
bit more belief in yourself because I
still need the videos for myself today
too so today let's learn some powerful
manifestation techniques enjoy
I really learned over a period of time
it's very critical insight to help me
get to where I am is to focus on them on
the end what is it I really want put
that Focus together and it's very
critical it's very interesting because a
lot of people have oh I would like this
and it's a broad General category and
then at some point it's like well it's
not specific enough you have to actually
say what it is you want I'll always
remember I was uh looking for a special
shirt to go to a Pink Floyd concert and
and I just all of a sudden visualize oh
it'd be neat to have a Russian shirt you
know with a collar that goes across here
and a couple of buttons down and I
thought oh yeah that would be really
great that would be cool shirt and then
I stopped and I was thinking where the
heck do you get a shirt like that I have
no idea in the world but I thought that
would be pretty good so I figure well I
still got to get something so I drive
off to a mall up near San Francisco and
I walk into the mall and there's a first
men's store over there and I go let's
start look and I have no idea and I walk
in and of course there's this big
circular rack of sale clothes and I
thought what the hell it's only a Pink
Floyd concert one night let's see what's
in there and I started going through the
rack and lo and behold oh my God a
Russian shirt right in the middle of
everything and it was like the shock of
oh my God there's a Russian shirt right
here
the enforce the unfortunate part of it
was I had the picture of a Russian chart
I said cool
I never said what the color was or
anything else I just had Russian shirt
and there was a Russian shirt color gray
no color at all why I didn't put in the
concept of color in the universe said
well just give it to him in Gray and it
was one of those things like oh be
conscious of what you're asking for
because the the more detail you put in
the more the universe can manifest a
resolution if you leave a lot of blanks
in what you want then all of a sudden
it's like well it's random whatever
fills in the blank because you never
said what you wanted you can have an
idea what you want and that's important
but the most important part of that just
having an idea is not just have a broad
idea I want X and I go no no what
exactly do you want why
go back to the principles of Science and
the principles of science reveal
something very important that principle
of science is this Consciousness is
creating our life experiences I go well
that sounds new agey I go no this is not
new Agee this is the primary principle
of quantum physics we are creators this
is a fact in fact uh quantum physics has
that but now let me add one other fact
epigenetics says the same thing because
epigenetics says your Consciousness is
controlling your behavior and your genes
and so it's time to stop for a second
and recognize where is your
Consciousness what are you thinking
about and the idea is start thinking all
those very positive thoughts but don't
try and tell the universe how it's going
to manifest okay you think of the
picture
let the universe get you there
and that's the most important lesson
I've learned I'm not telling the
universe how I'm going to get there I'm
just saying universe is where I want to
go
and then the universe will take care of
it it's so powerful it's so wonderful
and I never believed in it for the first
40 50 years of my life but I can tell
you now the life that I'm manifesting
today is a consequence of just what I
said focus on the end don't tell the
universe the means to get there
technique number two is overcome your
poverty mindset with Eckhart Tolle I
have an incredibly strong poverty
mindset which drags me down and keeps me
continually worrying about small things
don't ever waste food
this mindset says inside me I better
keep this because I might need it
someday I'll never be able to afford
that
those thoughts are unending
how can the power of presence help me
shed this crushing burden
good well
Let's uh
the good
the good news is that the questioner is
already
aware or let's say let's say I'm going
to address the question as you because I
assume the question is listening and
watching
so the good thing is that you are
already aware
of those thoughts and this is not the
natural thing they are still
millions of people
who have these or other types of
conditions thinking
and are completely unaware
that they have
whatever type of condition thinking it
is that they have they are unaware
because
they are 100 identified with that
condition thinking so that they don't
recognize it as conditions thinking that
is how they perceive reality that is
what determines the reactions and these
are self-repatuating thoughts that
continuously create the same emotions
and this then becomes a person's reality
they inhabit that reality and it is
totally
not just colored but distorted
by the conditioning of their mind so
that they think these thoughts but
they cannot differentiate between
reality and those thoughts
so
you already
know that you have
these types of thoughts so that's a
already an indication that
there has been an Awakening of
Consciousness or which is
the arising of awareness
awareness is the dimension
that is deeper and vaster than thought
and so
when you become aware of what your mind
is doing then
that is a sign
that the
Awakening process in you has already
begun so that's a wonderful thing
no
it does not necessarily mean that
immediately
you become free of the effect of those
thoughts so the thoughts still have a
certain power
and their power is to create certain
emotions
reactions and certain actions
out in the world
but while this still happens
there is in you
an observing a presence in the
background and that's also where the
possibility of freedom
comes in the possibility of choice
the possibility of not acting out those
thoughts
provided
that in the moment of these thoughts or
one of these thoughts occurring
you can still be there as the
observing presence as the awareness
and if you are then no you may not
fully realize this
but when you're able to watch a thought
like that
then the possibility arises that you can
you you no longer need to be controlled
by the thought
let's give an example in your case
um
let's say you have certain objects that
you oh I want I need to hang on to this
because I might need it one day I must
keep this and must keep it perhaps you
have already accumulated many things
that you actually don't use
and whenever this happens or you instead
of
letting go of something your mind says
no you must hang on because you might
need it one day so you can bring in you
recognize the thought and you realize
you do not have to act out the thought
so you can ask yourself what happens if
I don't act out this thought and I do
almost the opposite of what this thought
is telling me for example
in the case of needing to hang on to
material objects that you probably won't
need
uh you can make it to practice
periodically to give things away
despite the fact that your thoughts are
telling you oh I must hang on but you
are there see awareness and the
awareness can override
the thought you don't have to fight the
thought the the awareness simply
overrides the thought and then from the
so then instead of uh
acting
uh
according to the thought your actions
and the right arise is no longer from
the thought it arises from the awareness
and then you can make it to practice to
give things away
and you may still find
your mind telling you oh no don't do
that but this can actually strengthen in
you
the dimension of presence or awareness
but by simply observing a thought
recognizing it and then
um realizing that that thought is not
actually intelligent it's conditioned
part of the conditioned minds and then
what arises then is the true
intelligence so we could call it also
the presence arising is also the
Awakening of true intelligence
and then you make it a practice to
give things away either to somebody you
know
or you bring it to a thrift store where
somebody else will you realize actually
somebody else will perhaps be able to
use whatever it is that you're giving
away and you and then you bring in
gradually then the thought will have
less power because you're no longer
continuously reinforcing it
but by your actions so that's one thing
you can do and
then
this sense of lack of course is uh part
of most people's
egoic Consciousness in your case it
manifests as
again let's take another thought that
you have mentioned
um
like I can't afford that I can't I must
keep my money for I might need need it
for but I can't afford to buy this now
so again you can observe a thought
like that
and occasionally
um
you may want to
acquire an object that has inherent
beauty or quality if you can afford it
you don't have to do something
a reckless with your money but instead
of always saying oh no don't I need to
keep my mind buy something as a
statement of abundance
something that has quality
um
uh that is beauty or quality or you
respondent doesn't even have to be
expensive or maybe something expensive
it could be that you buy a pair of shoes
that cost three times as much as what
you would normally buy and
not just because it happens to have a
label that's famous for but it could be
that they're actually much better
quality and they will last three times
or more longer than others whose
so as a statement of abundance uh
occasionally you may want to buy
something that is as beauty or inherent
quality to it
another wonderful practice to counteract
this type of mental conditioning
is to I mention it's it's another aspect
of what I mentioned at the beginning and
that is to give what to give away not
just objects but occasionally to give
to give is a powerful statement of
abundance
so if you give to someone uh what
doesn't matter where it is let's say
it's somebody in the street there's
somebody there's a a bad guy in the
street and uh and you give this person
not a comparative thing in your mind
that from now on you have to give to
everybody you see it at a straight
corner but you but you can make it a
practice habitually
uh regularly
to give as a as a spiritual practice
because it's it's an affirmation of
it's the opposite of lack when you give
it's an affirmation of abundance
and it's a very pleasant thing to do
and then you might also want to give a
small amounts of money away even if you
don't have a lot uh the act of giving is
what really matters so whether it is to
a person who that you happen to know
who needs something or somebody you come
across seemingly accidentally or you
give to a charity that who
SE course you believe in
and feel good about and
so again and then you will probably
encounter your mind telling you that you
cannot afford to do this you must hang
on and then you again you're aware
enough
to recognize those thoughts and realize
that these are conditioned thoughts and
then you do the opposite
and then gradually you assume when you
no longer reinforce the thoughts through
your action the thoughts
um
will lose their power and greatly they
will not appear again technique number
three is make appreciation a daily habit
with Gabby Bernstein I want to end on
the power of appreciation you talk about
appreciation I think appreciation is
honestly like the biggest super tool in
the damn Universe for shifting our
energy and attention you shared the
Al-Anon lesson being grateful doesn't
mean we have to be happy about
everything but grateful for the lessons
we can accept that even the tough
moments are Divine lessons that guide us
back to love
appreciation I just feel like gosh the
moment you find yourself in the state
right that's the thing that's it that's
the thing and it's if you can't
appreciate whatever is happening that
you perceive to be wrong it's like we
have an opportunity to maybe look
someplace else like am I still breathing
yeah yeah yes okay it's a good day do I
still have a roof over my head yep I
think that the the appreciation
dissolves the boundary of fear and
appreciation creates more of what you
want
so if you've got something good going on
go appreciate it even more talk about it
thrive in it write about it feel it
meditate on the feeling of it because
then you create more of it if you're in
a funk lean on what you appreciate to
get you out of that funk and make
appreciation a daily habit you know like
when you and Josh go wake up in the
morning Abraham Hicks has this thing
called the appreciation game where you
can just play the appreciation game and
just say I appreciate you because you
make me coffee and I appreciate you
because you're a good dancer I'm just
thinking about you because you're so
funny on television whatever it is you
know but just just really appreciating
your spouse your children and and play
that game with your children oh my
goodness start your day going back and
forth with why you appreciate one
another and immediately just realigns
you puts you into this state where you
feel so good because how can you if you
can't feel bad in the presence of
appreciation yeah and it will catapult
you out of the negativity and that's
what this is all about this is all about
taking these moments and using these
methods and these practices to
consciously and proactively Bridge
yourself from that low vibration to a
better feeling emotion and in that
better feeling emotion you become a
super attractor also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
technique number four is work on your
skills with John Assaraf let me make you
very very clear about some thing
everybody everybody
has a money story
it's the thing that you tell yourself
about how much you can worth uh how much
you are worth how much are you worth in
the marketplace and there's two types of
stories you tell yourself you tell
yourself a story about what you think
you're worth but then there is the
hidden story
of what you really believe you're worth
so let me share with you another slide
it's called the Cornerstone okay of your
money story and the Cornerstone of your
money story we can show that please
chase the Cornerstone okay of your money
story
is your self-worth
and your efficacy your self-worth and
your efficacy so what is that
well self-worth is what you believe you
are worth in the market and efficacy is
all about your skills and your abilities
to accomplish something so if you feel
that you can accomplish something
because you have the knowledge you have
the skills you have the ability
then you're gonna have a higher level of
belief
in the marketplace but if you have
counter beliefs that say you're not good
enough you're not smart enough you're
not deserving enough
you are going to polarize yourself
around that so your beliefs and your
habits around money is your persona
persona just means what if you think
about what is a mask a mask okay is a
persona it's a mass that we put on
ourselves and so people who earn a lot
of money have okay a Persona a belief
that they can achieve more they will
achieve more they know how to have the
knowledge and the skills and they have
the habits to achieving more money so
that means that one of the things that
you need to do in order to earn more
money is ask yourself this question how
can I take my product my knowledge my
skills my abilities and bring it to the
marketplace so one or ten or a hundred
or million people will exchange their
money with me for that knowledge skill
product or service that I have and so
when you start thinking about money as a
means of exchange but also
from that
looking at your self-worth
and your knowledge and your skills
that is the beginning of changing
what you are able to earn in the
marketplace does this make sense so far
because before I continue to a couple
more things around
around your skills and showing you
another chart that I have which is a
really really important chart let me
know if this makes sense all right does
this make sense all right because I
think it does but let me just make sure
that that makes sense all right because
it's the marketplace that's paying you
if you have a job you're getting paid
based on what that job is worth in the
marketplace you want to make more money
at work you have to increase your value
to the company if you want to make more
money in your business you have to get
better at getting your message your
product your service and the benefits of
it to many many more people in the
marketplace so if you don't have the
knowledge or the skills of how to do
that you are going to be limited and if
you feel limited that's going to affect
your self-worth and your persona of how
you show up in the marketplace because
it's the marketplace that pays you and
the marketplace has a value a grain is
worth x a diamond is worthwhy a very
expensive rare painting is worth z a
certain type of yacht is worth x a row
boat is worth why the marketplace
determines value
you have to determine where you fit into
the marketplace and there are two things
you have to work on
your Knowledge and Skills to rise above
the other people in the marketplace who
are offering and have what you have
what makes somebody better than somebody
else at something knowledge skills
expertise and you have to make a
decision what level of the money game do
you want to play do you want to play at
the grade school level high school level
University level or at the pro level if
you just use sports or knitting or chess
is an example
people with different levels of skills
play at higher levels of the game and so
if you want to understand how to make
both loads of money you have to
understand the inner game your beliefs
your perceptions your values your habits
you have to understand
what is it that holds you back what is
it that drives you forward I'm going to
get into that for just a moment but you
have to raise your level of awareness of
the game the rules of the game and your
knowledge and your skills and you have
to raise your deserve ability score let
me repeat that you have to raise your
deservability score what you believe you
really in your heart not you know
haphazardly but in your heart you have
to raise what you believe you're worth
and how do you do that
you figure out how do you bring more
value in the marketplace
how do you bring more value to your
employer technique number five is use
the power of your thoughts with Rhonda
Byrne this person says many Law of
Attraction trainers
state that action is very important
along with thoughts just thinking about
becoming a millionaire won't a
billionaire pardon me a billionaire
won't make one a billionaire you need to
act so I didn't say you didn't need to
act but I do want to share a story with
you Sarah Blakely the CEO of Spanx asks
for a billion dollar idea
and she received the inspiration for
Spanx
and it certainly became a billion dollar
business
but because of the way that Sarah went
about that Sarah's experience of turning
that idea for start she had the
wherewithal to know without a doubt that
she had been given a billion dollar idea
she knew it and so she followed through
on that idea and she therefore would
have been The Universe just would have
lined up people's circumstances and
events for her it would have helped
guide her so she didn't go down the
wrong track with products it it would
have helped her see mistakes early on
before she went into manufacturing it
would have guided her would have
presented her with the most fantastic
people with the most fantastic fabrics
and everything that she needed to make
that a billion dollar business there's
no way
Sarah Blakely could have created Spanx
without asking for that billion dollar
idea do you see the power of thought
it's incredible and you have that power
technique number six is study the laws
of abundance with Deepak Chopra what is
the best way
to understand
money and what is the best way to
generate it
what is the best way to spend it
and what is the best way to earn it
and with that in mind I I created these
these seven laws that follow the same
principles
of the seven spiritual laws
okay and I'm going to call them the
seven laws of abundance
first law of
abundance is that the source of
abundance is infinite
once again the source of abundance
is infinite
why because the source of every
experience is consciousness
and consciousness
is by definition non-local has no form
and therefore it's infinite and the
source of all experience is
infinite and therefore
it can never be in short supply
so
if you think deeply about this first law
the source of abundance is infinite then
of course we want to get in touch with
that source and that source is
our innermost being which is the field
of all possibilities the field of
unpredictability and the source of
intention and desire the field of
um
that is evolving in the direction of
Truth goodness Beauty Harmony
and love the field that is inexhaustible
as
a source for ongoing
creativity and abundance
and it is simple to get in touch with
this source by transcending the Mind
through meditation
through self-awareness
through self-reflection
through self-inquiry
through mindful awareness of
every experience mindful awareness of
body mindful awareness of the processes
of the Mind mindful awareness of the web
of relationship mindful awareness of
mental space
and
to engage this source of infinite
possibilities
by asking questions and receiving
answers I've been in the habit of doing
that every day all my life and reviewing
this process every night before I go to
sleep
law number one
the source of abundance is infinite
number two
whatever you want to receive and let's
say
this is the second Law whatever you want
to receive start by giving so we can you
know start with the simple things
if you want attention you pay attention
to others if you want respect
you give respect to others
if you want
love you give your love to everyone that
you meet
and
respect love
attention affection
appreciation acceptance a very simple
things to start with but if you want to
generate wealth then figure out a way to
generate wealth for others
and also
figure out
how you can
activate abundance Consciousness in
others and one way to do this is also to
experience gratitude so when you
experience gratitude it opens the door
to abundance consciousness
so think of all the things you're
grateful for material things
relationships health
on and on career and as you open the
door
of
gratitude it leads to
the realm of abundance
start with giving once in a while when
I'm in New York City I go to the bank
and I get some cash
and then I walk around the city
giving cash
or dollars to homeless people on the
street
and don't do it casually do it sincerely
look them in the eyes
talk to them
and see their reaction when you give
them twenty dollars or whatever you'll
see the Gratitude in your eyes and you
feel a connection
between spirit and spirit
and so this exchange by the way that's
what money is also called The Exchange
the currency of exchange so start with
that
process and live in that process don't
stop
the flow of abundance by holding money
if you hold money it's of no use
right
what are you going to do with it
if you just hoard it
spend it spend it on yourself spend it
on others spend it on you friends
spend it on
charity spend it for a cause spend it
for an experience and exactly always
think what's the best use of the money
that I have
okay
that's number two
number three and these are just
principles right now that I can expand
on if you want me to
if you want me to do in this write about
this as I'll listen for your feedback
and I'll really expand on this
okay law number three money is the
exchange of values in fact the way a
society spends money is
no clue to their values
so right now most wealthy Nations and
even some unwealthy Nations poor nations
are spending money on weapons on
mechanized death on drugs on alcohol on
gambling on sleazy stuff and that only
represents the collective consciousness
of
bad money Bad Karma and therefore stay
away from any way that generates money
through harm
and this is what the great teacher of
all time the Buddha he said
right livelihood so right livelihood is
that kind of livelihood that
creates
joy in the world that increases
abundance in the world increases and
improves the quality of life in the
world
okay I understand that when you're
exchanging money you're exchanging
values
okay
law number four or principle number four
wealth is a state of consciousness
it's not the amount of money it's the
State of Consciousness that you can
generate wealth and abundance
and so what is that State of
Consciousness it's actually a state of
consciousness that I call spontaneous
creativity
spontaneous creativity and comes when
there is
um
a pause between
what we call
experience the gap between thoughts the
gap between
intention the gap between perception the
gap between breath
the space between choices
same place which I mentioned in the
first
principle the infinite
self
where there is spontaneous creativity
you know when there is spontaneous
creativity when there is no resistance
when there is no anticipation
when there is no regret
when you're totally present
and you're experiencing what is called a
flow because you know deep inside you
that your only intention
ultimately is the progressive expansion
of happiness for yourself and for
everyone else
and as you do that then that spontaneous
creativity
will activate
intention
which will find the creative
source
for fulfilling that intention as I have
said so many times before intention has
organizing power
and intention
organizes its own fulfillment
so that leads to the fifth principle
which is intention and attention in the
field of infinite possibilities is all
that matters intention and intention in
the field in field of infinite
possibilities
have the intention of what you want to
create with the abundance you have and
then with that intention
go and
transcend and when you transcend you
transcend to the source and there are
many ways of transcending
through music through a walk in nature
through
poetry through dance
whirling through meditation through play
and
through Collective
what I call Collective envisioning
Collective envisioning when you have a
group of people who have a vision
together
when you have an open system when you're
totally transparent when
you invite
even absurd ideas when you make unlikely
connections then something emerges and
we call that emergence
so create a group
for wealth Consciousness and if you
create that group and if you're
transparent and if you invite
unlikely alliances if you have maximum
diversity of people from the Arts from
the humanities from Sciences
from any field technology mathematics
whatever
and you sit and incubate together with
attention and intention then emergence
happens just happens and the emergence
of
abundance in this case with the proper
attention and intention and even
Collective intention I know somebody in
New York who just raised 450 million
dollars
through crowdsourcing and for creating a
place
for
spiritual enlightenment
but this is how they did it
crowdsourcing with authenticity with
sincerity with integrity
and with joy
so that leads to the sixth principle
here the key to abundance is Letting Go
in previous books I have mentioned
I think the Law of Detachment so this
simply means process orientation
and understanding that no experiences
grasping and clinging actually prevent
the flow
that intention and attention needs
to
reach its destination
so no clinging no grasping
letting go is the secret
and finally
the seventh principle
the purpose of wealth of course is to
create joy and expand happiness
for us and for everybody else
in a sense I followed these principles
all my life and I have to say that my
journey has been one of effortless
spontaneity
um and I don't apologize for success
and I don't apologize for the fact that
spirituality can be a source of
abundance and wealth
because
if you feel guilty about wealth then you
feel guilty about money then you will
end up with guilt
and no wealth at the same time that's
not a good state of being and technique
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is shift your
mindset with Marissa peer if you are
creating wealth and doing great things
with it the more good you can do the
more your mind will set you on fire to
go out and get it
so I want you to think about how your
world would change and how other
people's world will change too when you
have abundance when you have Abundant
Health
abundant wealth abundant love when you
have an abundant mindset and you never
go oh I don't know where it's coming
from and what if they leave and oh my
God what if it doesn't work out what if
I get rejected if you just decide I live
in an abundant world and there's enough
for everyone and if I have more it
doesn't mean other people have less
because I have a generous heart and I
want more to help other people
in me having more I can do good things
I'm a happy I'm a better parent a better
person a better partner a better better
daughter son brother sister husband wife
lover boss employer employee think about
all the goods you can do
and how when you go from zero to
abundance you show other people it's
possible too there are people in the
world now we look and think wow that guy
came from India with no education and
founded this fashion
site
because the old days of going to UNI
going to college coming from wealth and
that time only they don't even exist
anymore
the people who have money now the people
who invented something came up with
something
monetized an idea
and we can all do that you can do that
you can do that now
so think about how people will benefit
don't identify
with all of those thoughts that are
jumping around everywhere and this takes
a little bit of practice right because
what might happen is
um let's think of some situation you're
at work and your boss kind of gets into
you about something and that's usually
when the monkey mind appears right when
you're upset and then it's just like
great got all this energy I'm gonna go
crazy boss always picks on me boss does
this what's this that and so when you
have a situation like that where the
mind is doing that just notice
the mind just notice it the minute that
you notice it you are no longer
believing it and your mind is going into
the background if you would just notice
those thoughts instead of believing
those thoughts so if your boss speaks
you out and then you and then you start
to have all of those thoughts and you
know what you might be two hours later
you might be the next morning and you've
still got all the thoughts coming and
then you suddenly remember notice the
thoughts
that is fantastic that you've remembered
because that noticing disempowers the
mind the more that you can notice and
not identify with those thoughts that
you don't want the weaker and weaker the
mind will get the negativity in the mind
and soon it's just going to be like a
little lamb that you can use for
whatever you want because that's all
that's the only reason why we created
the mind we created the mind for my this
is what my teacher told me this and I
love it we created the mind for one
reason to to manifest what we want on
Earth that's why we've got it it's not
our psychologist it doesn't know
anything about psychology it's not our
psychiatrist it doesn't know anything it
doesn't know anything about your mum it
doesn't know anything about your best
friend or your boss so just keep it in
its right category and
um and then
you will start to lessen the impact of
your mind and that Mikey mine will start
to get quieter and quieter the beautiful
thing about monk life is half the day is
self and half the day is service that's
how you're taught to live okay so the
morning hours are for you to fill
yourself it's almost like putting on
mental emotional and physical armor like
that's what a morning routine is odd
days are tiring our days are busy our
days are draining well guess what if you
didn't put your armor on in the morning
and you're going out to battle
how many knives are going to cut you how
many swords are going to pierce you how
many wounds are you going to come home
with how many of you come back home
feeling wounded I come back home feeling
wounded sometimes but guess what if you
put your armor on in the morning a
warrior would never go out onto a
Battlefield
and life can be a battlefield work can
be full of conflict sometimes your
relationships can be damaging sometimes
your friendships can be toxic sometimes
so we are warriors in one sense and so
without wearing that so for me a morning
routine is putting on emotional armor
which is meant to protect you for the
rest of the day and that way even if you
do get pierced or you do get popped or
you do get cut you're protected and I
know that when I my morning routine is
at its best I feel protected I know
exactly whereas when my morning routine
is weakened I feel weak and so for me
the morning routine as I get strategic
about it there's two principles you have
to know
location has energy and time has memory
if you do something in the same place
every day that place now holds that
energy
and this is huge like it's it's just so
big and I'm grateful for that reaction
because people don't realize how how
powerful this is like when I meditated
in temples that were 5 000 years old in
South India it was easier to meditate
because people have been meditating
there for thousands of years and so when
you find a space in your home and even
if you've got like I lived in a 500
square foot apartment in New York four
years ago and I just had a tiny Corner
which I dedicated to my sacred practices
so if you you don't have to have a big
home to do this you don't have to be
wealthy to do this you can find just a
corner in your home that you dedicate as
your meditation space or your reflection
space so first thing location has energy
second thing time has memory and this is
something that people underestimate when
you do something at the same time every
day
you remember it and time remembers it
that's why we struggle to work out at
different times every day it's why we
struggle like why do we feel hungry at
the same time every day generally we
feel hungry at the same time most people
if you've got regulated diet you're full
hungry you'll feel tired at the same
time every day you will look towards
that coke can or that sugar or that
chocolate bar at the same time every day
and so when you're meditating at the
same time if you're exercising at the
same time so what I recommend to people
wow is your morning routine needs four
aspects and it's simple and I call it
time it's about making time in the day
okay so time stands for t-i-m-e T stands
for thankfulness there needs to be even
if it's five minutes five minutes of
thankfulness of gratitude every single
morning and that has to be gratitude
that's specific it can't be gratitude
that's generic so generic gratitude is
something that anyone could be grateful
for oh I'm grateful for the sky I'm
grateful for air I'm grateful for water
that's cool but it's generic gratitude
specific gratitude is I'm grateful for
the fact that I have someone calling me
this morning I'm grateful for the fact
that I can still call my parents I'm
grateful for the fact that I have this
person in my business who is having such
an impact I'm grateful you know it's
specificity yeah so thankfulness second
one is Insight I think this is one thing
that a lot of people are missing which I
recommend people listening to you it's
like podcast books and and make it
easier for yourself if you get this book
leave it open on your bedside table
leave it open on your kitchen table
leave it open on your dining table I
guarantee you you will read more and
what you read will speak to you and I
think people underestimate that that
literally like when you have it open and
you'll just flick to a chapter randomly
and you'll pick up one line it will
impact you and it'll speak to you so
Insight you need Insight every day m is
meditation and I believe meditation is
different for different people as monks
we did walking meditations we did Beach
meditations we did visualizations we did
breath work find your meditation
practice I give a ton in the book and
fourth obviously exercise which you can
speak to even more than I can I exercise
to keep fit you look amazing too though
but it's an exercise everyone needs to
find five minutes a day 15 minutes a day
of exercise just give yourself
permission
to want the things that you want and
unless you believe that you're worthy
unless that you practice love you're
never going to think that you deserve
the things that you want right so tell
the story
okay so I'm probably gonna I mean
I'll shorten it so the bottom line is
that so in
1990 I was a senior in college at
Dartmouth and my parents came to visit
from Western Michigan and we went to
this place called Simon Pierce which is
a famous glass blowing Mill and as we
walked into the restaurant I had an
experience
that you may be able to relate to and
that is I walked in and I immediately
saw this painting hanging on the wall
and it was about the size of a door only
horizontal and it was a Vermont
landscape and I was drawn into it
immediately like I was no longer in that
restaurant I was standing in that field
I could feel that breeze I'd never ever
had an experience like that with a
painting I've never had an experience
like that with art no I mean not like
that not like that I mean my yeah my
sense was that this is very atypical for
you very
so I
kind of lost it the the the the
restaurant was quiet and then
I leaned back and suddenly kind of back
in the moment I'm like I'm gonna own
this painting someday
it just that was what was right there
and I looked at the price and said like
three thousand dollars I'm like not
today and I went back and I sat down and
that was it but the painting never left
my mind you see there's something called
The zeigon Arc effect I always say it
wrong but it's like there's a checklist
in your brain that when you have a
moment where you're like this is
important your brain puts it on a
checklist yeah it's like a notch yes a
notch happens and now your brain as part
of the filter in the brain is always
going to be kind of scanning the
subconscious to let anything into your
mind related to that incident it can be
positive by the way like with the
painting or this is how trauma happens
too like you have this high intensity
emotional experience that notches
something in your brain and now your
brain kicks in to remember
so uh bottom line is uh I always thought
about that painting
years go by
whenever somebody would say Vermont I'd
think of the painting
I don't know why I can't explain it
never wanted a painting before was not
an art student it's going to Lost like
you're not collecting Arts no no and so
I you know fast forward the story 10
years and my uh Chris and I are engaged
and we're going to go up to Vermont to
see the leaves and immediately I'm like
we got to go to Simon Pierce I got to
show you the painting so we pull up to
the mill and we walk in and right in
front there is Boom a painting by the
same artist Gail Shepard and I'm like oh
my God it's here and we race all around
the place
and it's gone
and the funny thing was and this is the
way your brain works Chris was more
disappointed than I was I literally
turned to him and said it's okay dude
like it'd be weird if we're still here
after 10 years I'm gonna track this
thing down I actually said to him you
know what's going to happen Chris
I'm gonna be able to buy this like 40
years from now it's going to be hanging
in the corporate Lobby of some building
and I'm gonna have to track down the
owner and pay like quadruple the money
they pay but I'm gonna own this thing
I'm Mission yes so a couple years pass
and
um it's my birthday I think I was
turning 30 and Chris says uh Chris gets
a couple people too
give money and he said I could buy
anything I wanted with it so I had what
500 bucks now I'm pregnant at the time
with our first kid
I should have bought a crib or stools
but for whatever reason the zeigon arc
effect takes over and I'm like the
painting so I call the mill and I get
this guy on the phone I'm like uh you
know I want to buy a kale Shepherd piece
and I said could you send me Polaroids
and he's like sure and I tell them the
budget and he goes I'll send you
Polaroids of some of her smaller things
and she's like blowing up in the
meantime right yeah she's a very very
successful Vermont landscape artist and
so I
I I say to him you know by the way
there's this one painting
and I describe the painting I'd seen
over 10 years ago and he said well that
was way before my time but I bet Gail
will know
and I'm like Gail you know Gail it's
like of course I know Gail she like
lives in in down the road
here's her number
so for two days I paced around the
apartment with 500 bucks in my pocket
driving Chris crazy because I felt like
what am I going to say to her and I must
be a weirdo I've been stalking this lady
I've been thinking about her for 10
years I can't afford a painting you know
what who am I to buy a painting like
what the hell
so finally Chris is like would you call
her I'm gonna call her you're driving me
crazy so I call her and I start talking
a mile a minute and she was amazing
and then
um I said by the way there was this one
painting and I go and I explain this
painting there's a stand of poplar trees
down the center and a big mountainscape
behind it and this beautiful blue
Vermont sky and geese flying information
overhead and
I could hear her thinking on the other
end of the line
and she said you know Mel I've done so
many large-scale
uh paintings over the years I'd hate to
mistake the one you're talking about but
I'll tell you what
if my husband and I meet you and Chris
at the Mill at Simon Pierce and we'll
walk all around and have lunch and I'll
tell you the stories behind every
painting and if you don't see what you
like there I'll take you back to my
studio which is a couple miles down the
river and you can look at everything I'm
working on and if you don't see anything
you like there then you can go through
all my slides and see if you can find
that painting that you saw 10 years ago
and I said deal
so a month passes we go up to the mill I
walk in we meet each other she's amazing
she's like twice our age just incredibly
cool lady she's walking around as we're
walking around looking at these
paintings Rich I've got I'm like eight
months pregnant I'm realizing
these are 10 times the amount of money
that I have
I can't afford this
like I don't I don't have this kind of
money
and I'm getting like more and more into
that imposter syndrome what am I doing
mode oh my God I'm so embarrassed I'm
meeting somebody I idolize I don't
deserve to be here right wasting her
time because she thinks she's going to
get a Payday out of this correct we sit
down
and she goes now that you're sitting
down I have something to tell you
um
she said there's only been two times in
my career as an artist
that I've done two studies of the same
peace
and your painting is one of them
it's one of a pair
she knew all along she knew all along
she was playing games with you about not
knowing which painting yeah and she said
the sister piece to the one that you saw
all those years ago is sitting in my
studio right now where it's been for the
past 11 years
I start sobbing everybody's like totally
emotional her husband's like you should
have seen her when you when she was on
the phone with you it was like she saw a
ghost so we get in the car
and we drive to the mill
and when we walk in they're in the
center of this massive kind of Barn
Studio space is an easel with a painting
taped up with painters tape on it and it
was
the sister to my painting there were
slight differences not as much movement
in the grass but it was
one of the most extraordinary
experiences of my life it was as if time
suspended and I was
standing before that painting in 1990
saying it would be mine
and there I was 11 years later
standing in front of it
and then I realized oh my God I can't
afford this
and Chris walks over and he's like
what's wrong and I'm like just promise
me someday like promise me that I don't
need a jewelry I don't need a car like
just promise me you will buy me this
thing
and he kind of leans over and goes hey
Gail how much for the big one and she
said um
Mel can have it for 500 bucks because
clearly when I was making it 11 years
ago I was making it for her
and so it hangs in my kitchen
it's on the back of the book
um this is the galley though right so
wait is it in the is it I think so yeah
yeah and
um it's a reminder every day that your
mind is designed to help you get what
you want
I never stop believing
that I could make it happen
and when you tell your mind what's
important to you
there is extraordinary science
that proves that your mind has a live
and ever-changing filter a live Network
that changes how it views the world What
it lets in what it blocks out and if you
program your mind correctly
and if you're clear about what you want
to create your mind will help you get
what you want when you have a goal in
your head it's not even a goal it's a
fantasy it's a dream when you have a
book like this you can call it your goal
book and you write out your goals and
you go through I'm just about to take
you through bit by a bit stage by stage
you go back to that but you can look at
it you can touch it you can just make it
real so remember if you do not write out
your goals as a plan and write out how
to accomplish them you don't have a goal
you have a wish you have a dream you
have a Daydream if you want to go get a
pen get a nice little book like this you
can do on your phone too you can make a
document in your computer
and be prepared to make your goals real
so let's start now get your book pause
this if you need to go and find one
create one and I want you to pick a goal
and do not even start with I want to
lose five pounds I want more money these
are what I call wishy washy girls no
if you can make your goals real you
might as well make them huge big
enormous phenomenal so if you say well I
want more money that's why I could go
hang on a minute hey I got ten dollars
here there you go you go well that's not
my goal but you said I want more money
and I learned this when I used to work
with women who were infertile that come
and go you know I just want to be
pregnant I want to be pregnant so bad if
I was just praying I go well as I look
at your notes you've been pregnant six
times I know I keep miscarrying
so being pregnant is not your goal is it
what
isn't your goal to carry to full term a
healthy robust bouncing baby to deliver
a perfect baby to be a great man yeah
that's my goal why don't you say that
because you can be pregnant lots of
times and never have a baby or you can
say my goal is to have a perfect baby
how about this my goal is to get lots of
attention for what a nervous twitch
explosive gas that will give you
attention but that's not what you want
is it nobody wants exclusive gas
so let's start with a big goal pause if
you need to
take some time open your book
and write out a big goal now you can
have a career goal and whatever I'm
going to have my own company create my
own business invent something you can
have a relationship goal my relationship
is wonderful we grow in loving and
respecting each other and you can have a
health goal
but I want you to pick one only one not
three not five not ten one goal it can
be career it can be health
can be love pick one goal
and then I want you to decide why you
want that goal so much so the first
thing is I have a goal I want to have my
own business that's my goal and now
you're going to go to a next page and
write out why do you want to have your
own business so much and the more
reasoned you can write out why the more
likely
you will make that goal real so write
down why write down as many why's as you
can and remember
you can come back any time to this and
think Oh I thought of another why and
another why so leave plenty of space
take your time when you've done your
whys go to another page and write out
who will benefit from you achieving that
goal of course you will but who who will
benefit for instance if you have your
own business
you will employ people who will benefit
maybe your kids will go to private
school maybe your business will allow
you to help your partner have their
business
the more people who will benefit from
you achieving your goal the more reasons
you have
to achieve that goal so write out who
will benefit from you achieving a Who
how and why will they benefit you're
going to buy your mama house put your
niece and nephew through private school
did you think of your mind as like the
genie in a bottle that says your wish is
my command
and I want you to understand that every
thought you think and every word you say
is a blueprint that your mind body and
psyche must make real so when you write
out your goals don't say I wish I could
be rich
I long to be in a loving relationship
write it as if it's already happening I
am a millionaire I am in a loving
relationship Michael that doesn't make
sense it does make sense because your
mind only works in the present tense
when you say next year I'll have a
bikini body it doesn't know what next
year is and so you must write your both
in the present tense I am I always I
have I do this new page is about your
discipline
how many hours a day are you going to
spend working on your goal
how often are you going to come back to
this book and look at it I want you to
write out I am
I always I have I do and I want you to
fill that in
you see the best goal in the world will
not work if you don't work and many
people fail at this point they write out
a goal
my goal is to be a millionaire my goal
is to be famous my goal is to be wildly
in love and I think that's it
it's not and if you want to be madly in
love writer all the reasons why but then
you have got to put yourself in front of
the kind of person you want to share
your life with
if you want to start your own business
and you have a reason why you also need
to have the discipline to meet people
who will fund you sponsor you joint
venture with you so I want you to really
understand that the best goal will not
work if you don't work you can have the
start point
but you have to keep going many of the
most successful people ever say well you
know I had a goal Luther Vandross had a
goal to be a rock star
and people said well you're an overnight
success he went I don't think so you
know I sang Jingles for KFC for 12 years
that's a long night 12 years and it all
said but Luther you're singing on
television that's cool you get paid a
lot of money for KFC I said yeah but
it's not my goal and he stuck it out and
many people have got so close to success
and had to keep going and you have to
keep going so
look at your Diesel and decide you will
give more to your goal give even more
work on it look at it write it out think
about it talk about it you must be
prepared to give so much to your goal in
fact you must be prepared to be
unstoppable in the pursuit of your goal
have you ever spent any time wondering
how does everything happen
how does everything happen why does the
night follow the day
why doesn't the day follow the day
back in some places it does
but
I spend a lot of time thinking about
this
at the times it almost drives me crazy
but my greater side of my studio here is
a Japanese maple tree
and
there's times of the year it's
absolutely beautiful
in the spring of the year it has buds on
and then the bud Chrome and leaves pop
out and the leaves generally in the
spring are a very deep greeny Brown
they're not a pretty looking leaf
but then they start to change and over
time you don't notice it happening just
one day you look and it's a different
color
and by fall
the leaves are crimson red they're the
most beautiful it is the most beautiful
tree and it's right outside in my studio
I'm sitting here in my desk and
cameras around me but out there is that
tree
and you know every fall the leaves turn
red
Every Spring there are greeny brown
they're not greeny brown in the fall and
red in the spring they're always red in
the faux and greeny brown in the spring
think about it
did you ever wonder why the tide goes
way out the tide comes way back in
I spent some time in the Navy in Canada
I was down on the East Coast for a while
and I was near the Bay of Fundy do you
know the Bay of Fundy has one of the
highest and lowest tides in the world
it's absolutely amazing it goes way out
and then comes way back in
same up around Prince George on the West
Coast
you go onto a ship and you might be
walking up a plank just right straight
up and you go off the ship sometimes
you're going right down that ship goes
way up near and it comes way down very
high very low tide now some place the
Tide's not very big they do have a tide
but not too high not too long
why is it so different in one place than
another
you know why does the leaves change
color
why do they change color
you know why does the grass keep growing
wouldn't it be so much nicer it's a
grass just you know just stayed at a
certain length you wouldn't have to cut
it but it would always look pretty
you know do you ever think about this do
you know that everything in this
universe happens in an exact way
and exactly not by chance but in an
exact way
when John Kennedy the president of the
United States actors asked Dr Warner Von
Braun who was the master mind behind the
space program we asked him what would it
take to build a rocket that would carry
a person to the moon and bring him back
safely to Earth Vaughn Brown answered
him in five words the will to do it
that's it the will to do it
he knew he didn't have to know how to do
it he knew he had to learn how to do it
but he didn't have to know to make up
your mind you were going to do it now
why did he say that because he
understands the laws
run runtime said after years of studying
the spectacular Mysteries of the cosmos
he was led into a firm belief in the
existence of God and he said the natural
laws of this universe are so precise
that we don't even have any difficulty
building spaceship we can send people to
the moon and we can climb the landing
with the Precision of a fraction of a
second
now he said these laws must have been
set by someone I see the laws as God's
modus operandi but I'm going to tell you
something everything happens by law when
you and I get in harmony with the law I
never do that odds are pretty good we
should understand them but when we get
in harmony with the law then I'm going
to tell you it's just smooth sailing
success
happens
probably be a good understanding good
idea to understand the laws wouldn't it
think about it
your life is governed by laws that are
not man-made so they're not going to be
man changed and if you study them and
work in harmony with them I'm going to
go shock yourself with the good you can
do now I've been doing that for the last
58 years I'm starting to get a really a
reasonable grip on them but I don't
understand them as well as I want to or
would like to
but I'm going to study a little more
today you know I get my trusty book out
here I'll have to talk to you about this
book
that'll be another talk
study the laws find out what they write
what they're like
what are the laws and then study them
you'll win consistent action is the
cure-all whatever problem you have
whatever issue you're facing whatever
big life you want to create for yourself
the way to get there is not some giant
short burst of effort it's the daily
consistent grinding action that will
help you accomplish your goals people
look at my channel and
a lot of new people have joined over the
past number of years hey welcome boy
great to have you welcome to believe
Nation it's a positive happy place it's
great to have you here it's an honor to
be a part of your daily routine
if you go and look at my my channel my
main channel in the history it took so
many years guys so many years of just
making content and not seeing any
results
I took I forget what the number is it
took five years to get to 9 000
something subscribers and another five
years to get almost two million
subscribers and I was sitting over three
million subscribers Etc
I haven't missed
an upload every single day
for I don't know
eight years
something crazy like that
every day
I've made videos through
travel I've made videos through elect
electricity electricity outages I made
videos through breaking my neck I made
videos through my tour I made videos
through vacation I made videos I made
videos I made videos I made videos I
made videos I made videos and you can
plan you can prepare you can get ahead
you can you can batch them
but I don't think your goals count until
they're hard
it's when it gets hard when when you get
tested that's when you have to show
yourself What You're Made Of
even little things like
I remember filming at my dance studio in
Toronto
and I have my camera guy and my
assistant and we're filming and the
electricity goes out
and then there's a fire alarm
they go I guess we can't film like the
first thing that that my camera guy says
is okay well I guess we can't film I
can't film but it's like electricity
outage and then fire alarm
you can't film with that it's like I'm
I'm filming today
so I took my phone it was freezing
outside I took my phone went outside and
just started filming
because videos have to go up
they have to go up
I've I've made videos with my broken
neck
I broke my neck in two spots had a
concussion
and I
next week I'm making videos
they weren't as long they weren't as
good
I'm wearing a neck brace if you look at
the old videos I'm wearing this giant
neck brace I got this giant scab here on
my forehead because I smashed my head
against the wall
when I fainted and that's how it led to
the concussion broken neck I'm still
making videos
not making videos is not an option
and so if you look at someone like me
who
is introverted is shy who doesn't like
the camera who always thought that
people who are famous had a big ego who
I still don't like being on stage I
still get nervous every single time
but I still have a message
and I still want to serve how does
somebody like that
have this kind of Channel well because
of every single day making videos you've
done over 10 000 videos I've done over
10 000 videos that's crazy
not all of them are public
but even just on the main Channel let
alone this channel on the top 10 Channel
all the other channel 10 000 Plus videos
over 12 years
why
how
it's just a consistent action
I think most people lose because
we overestimate what we can do
in a really
short period of time and underestimate
what we can do in a long period of time
you think by putting in three weeks of
hard work you're going to crush it
but really if you just stayed on it like
guys you've had ideas you have enough
you've you have had an idea
that you'd love that you gave up on too
soon that if you just kept doing it this
is an idea that you had maybe three
years ago that if you just found the way
to keep doing it even part-time even on
the side even on the weekends if you
just kept at it you'd be in a different
place right now
something would have happened something
would have paid off
but we're too frustrated to get
something to happen right now and I get
it I'm there too I'm I'm impatient I
want immediate results I want things to
happen I'm putting my best I want this
video right now to be the best one I've
ever done and I put my effort to try to
make that happen and I fully recognize
at the same time that
it's a long game
that you have to keep going
and that if it's your purpose you can't
give up on it
most people just quit too soon
you just quit too soon
and that's you quitting on your dream
and if it's your dream and you want it
to happen it's a daily consistent I have
action to make it happen
so how do you do it let me give you some
tactics so that you can not just get
motivated from a message but actually
apply it to your life number one you
have to create a calendar
these videos happen because they're in
my calendar
I'm filming this on a Tuesday Tuesday is
my YouTube day I always film on Tuesday
I block it off in my calendar
I just came back from vacation and on
the Tuesday of my week I was still
making videos people say well you still
work on vacation first off it's not work
like I like this this is fun for me this
isn't this isn't oh I have to go make
videos if that was my mindset I would
I'd be out I wouldn't do it anymore
but also if you're on vacation you're
making videos or you're doing a little
bit of work
spend three hours
of a 24-hour day
doing something
is totally achievable somebody one of
the people that I invested into
yesterday's like how do I take a
vacation on my business
like how do I my wife wants to know how
do I go on vacation and run this
business like you can still you can
either plan ahead and get ahead with all
your clients or you can still do some
work
do you not have personal time are you
going to be around your wife 24 hours a
day does your wife not want to go to the
spa or spend some time on the beach it's
not about the three hours that you spend
working it's about
the other hours at 21 hours you get to
sleep but whatever all the other hours
that you have the other day it's about
intentional time most of most people's
life is not intentional most of your
vacation time is not intentional either
if you were to spend 21 hours a day with
your wife
intentionally creating an amazing
relationship
then the three hours a day you're gonna
spend working
as easy as nothing
of course you could take time off
but you have to put in your calendar
you have to create a calendar that makes
sense for you schedule in when you're
actually going to make your dreams
happen because otherwise it's a dream I
could say I want to make YouTube videos
but if it was never my calendar guess
what it would never happen and this
applies for life too every uh every
afternoon
at 2 30 I spend time with Nina with my
wife
we spend time in the morning I take an
intentional break at 2 30 we go to the
park we take we take the dogs with us
we we stay inside and just be together
if it's raining like we'll spend time
every day every weekday at 2 30 because
I want I wanted to spend more time with
Nina during the week weekends we're
basically all in on on the relationship
but the weekdays can be crazy you know
so we spend time in the morning we spend
time in the evening and I wanted to
spend 2 30 it's 25 minutes together but
intentional 25 minutes that intentional
25 minutes is worth more than three
hours of just sit in front of a TV
that's not time together
you have a lot more time than you think
you're just not being intentional that's
the problem if you feel like you got to
the end of the week and you were so busy
but you got nothing done
and everything's falling apart you're
just not intentional with your time
so you schedule it in whatever you
wanted a life whatever your dream life
looks like whatever your goals Ambitions
motivations are put in your calendar
two
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
stop letting yourself off the hook
for not following through on your
calendar
I'm a little tired today because we just
came back from our trip I'm a little jet
lagged from coming out from the West
I'm still making videos I'm still videos
have to be made they're going up like
when do you let yourself break
if it's in the calendar it has to happen
videos have to happen today I don't care
if I'm lying in bed I don't care I don't
care if I'm in the hospital I've made
videos from the hospital I don't care
where videos have to come up I don't
care if they're the best videos they're
the best
with what I can make right now
if I'm tired they might be lower than my
standard
but it's the best of what I can make
right now if I'm in the hospital it's
definitely lower than what I can make
out of the hospital but I'm gonna make
the best of what I can make right now
be the person who follows through on the
things that you say you're gonna do
because the next time you put something
in your calendar the next time we see
you're gonna get that goal or
do this project you're going to the next
day wake up I'm not I can't do that I'm
not doing that
you're starting to build the identity
either way of the person who follows
through or the person who doesn't follow
through
and every time you say yes to yourself
every time you do it when it's difficult
you start to build up that identity a
little bit more of I follow through I
follow through I follow through so then
the next time you put something in your
calendar the next time come up with a
goal you start to believe that it's
actually possible for you to do it
because you're building that identity of
you being the person who actually
follows through
and every time you let yourself off the
hook every time you give yourself a
break every time you say it's okay I'm
not going to do it today every time you
say that
you eat away at that other identity and
start to build a new one
the new identity of the person who
doesn't follow through
you start to believe yourself a little
bit less
the next goal you write down is a little
less credible you don't think you can do
it you're going to realize the next day
that you're not going to follow through
it's very
slippery slope to fall down
so step one is you build a calendar step
two is you become the person who sticks
to your calendar
who follows through on the things that
you say you're gonna do that's why it's
important to create a realistic calendar
don't tell me don't tell yourself you're
gonna make 100 videos a day every day
you're going to make a thousand phone
calls a day every day
you're not you're going to write 100
love letters to your wife every day
you're not you're not it's not going to
happen make it a realistic plan for
something you can actually stick to
because again if you just stick to it
guys you will hit your goals
if you stop quitting on yourself if you
stop letting yourself off the hook that
idea you had three years ago should have
already come to Creation because you
just stuck with it just stick with it
step number three so create a calendar
one stick to your calendar number two
three
the environment around you really
matters
videos like this really matters why
create the inspressor to be with you
every morning to give you the Boost to
bring you people like John asroff and
Oprah and Elon Musk and these people who
lift you up who inspire you hopefully
that's the intention every time
join a group like movement makers be a
part of a community be around other
entrepreneurs who are doing things we're
chasing their dreams we're trying to
make their thing happen when you're when
you create that environment and you
start to shift it
it inspires you to want to play bigger
it inspires you to want to stay
consistent when you are feeling at your
lowest low when you're about to quit on
the thing that you said that you want to
do that's in your calendar you see it
you see it today I'm supposed to do that
like I don't want to do that what brings
you out of it
it's the habits it's the environment
it's the routine
watch another video
join our group like movement makers
get a mentor coach
have an accountability buddy
you have to be around the people who
constantly fill your cup who give you
light who lift you up who make you
believe and help you feel like it's
possible when you do those three things
your life will change
create a calendar
that Maps your actions to your ambitions
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
and then be around the people videos
resources environment
that encourages you that lifts you up
and makes you feel like it's possible
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to activate the Law of Attraction
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there 95 of who we are
is those unconscious programs so then
becoming conscious of your unconscious
self or how many times do we have to
forget and go unconscious